[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys wenn ihr
seht es schon ich brauche jetzt keine
große ankündigung auch in diesem jahr
gibt es wieder einen adventskalender
ihr habt ihr euch gewünscht ich sehe
wirklich schon seit wochen auf einem
kanal immer wieder den kommentar
sally macht auch in diesem jahr wieder
einen adventskalender und wer muss jetzt
wieder mit brent news
zusammengeschlossen mit dem daniele und
haben gedacht kommt in diesem jahr
machen wir wieder einen kalender der
kalender ist wirklich ganz besonders das
ist nicht einfach nur ein
adventskalender wo man jeden tag ein
türchen öffnet und schnell was machen
kann ist dann adventskalender mit
lebensmitteln dies zum einen entweder
gar nicht im supermarkt gibt weil es
super leute sind oder einfach ganz
besondere lebensmittel die super zur
weihnachtszeit passen und eben auch zu
uns passen zu uns als bank community
das heißt ihr könnt die lebensmittel
vernaschen oder eben auch zum backen und
teilweise auch zum kochen benutzen
ich habe mir natürlich 24 türchen und
wenn ihr jetzt sagt ich möchte gar nicht
wissen was in diesem adventskalender für
lebensmittel sind dann schaltet am
besten jetzt aber ihr könnt auch gerne
dran bleiben und schauen was ich gleich
alles auspacken
für mich ist es auch eine überraschung
das heißt ich werde einfach ein paar
türchen öffnen
ich würd mal sagen sie sie zwischen 15
und 20 werden mit euch durch schauen was
alles drin steckt und dann mache ich
wieder eine challenge das heißt ich
versuche dann daraus weihnachtliches
gebäck oder weihnachtliche gerichte zu
kochen oder zu backen
was denkt wahrscheinlich eher backen und
dann schauen wir einfach mal was heute
leckeres passiert und im laufe des
videos gibt es übrigens noch eine
überraschung ein gewinnspiel das ist
ehrlich aber später ich glaube wir
fangen jetzt direkt anderen packen weil
die türchen aus ich zeige euch und dann
starten wir auch gleich mit dem backen
der daniela ist übrigens auch da wirst
du vielleicht kurz hallo sagen in meinem
video hallo ja später darf der daniela
ausprobiert und ich würde auch sagen die
jungs aus dem team dürfen auch wir wären
ja natürlich
nachdem weil ich wusste was entsteht
und falls ich jetzt ne frage habt zu
diversen lebensmitteln frage ich einfach
den absoluten und auf dem ren news kanal
da werden wir übrigens auch die ganzen
lebensmittel noch mal ganz genau
vorstellen
bei mir machen wir so ein unboxing kurz
und knapp und bei euch erfahren
perfekt also wenn ihr das video
anschauen und schott brennt nicht vorbei
okay gut starten wir ich fange jetzt
nicht mehr einfangen sondern
durcheinander und übrigens bei euch sind
die lebensmittel dann anders verpackt
das heißt ja ok katina creme chocolat
aus der schweiz ja viele schweizer
zuschauer ein leckerer boot auf sich
warten da muss jetzt einfach dran
riechen sehr schokoladig 300 gramm für
aufs brot oder auf crêpes oder als top
empfehlung gleich zwei produkte bio
zitronenschale von ruf und bio rochade
von ruf schokolade jack white manila
mit ghana vanille schokolade salz
glutenfreie reines chaos
das ist echt interessant da bin ich mal
gespannt
wahrscheinlich ein toller mail
ersatzfamilie
niederegger trüffel freestyle mit
chocolate cup trophy und blue chips
trade also leckere truppen in drei
verschiedenen geschmacksrichtungen
seeberger gebrannte mandeln hat sie
schon richtig grantig hat das hat auch
so was packt man ausland kann es gleich
falschen oder direkt weiterverarbeitet
ok bisher war echt alles sehr gut ein
getränk das kenne ich
wir hatten nämlich schon mal ein eps von
trink- und es war echt ziemlich cool
dieser hier ist mit vanillegeschmack das
heißt einen ersten drink vegan als
mensch ersatz und vor allem eine tolle
proteinquelle also vanilla darf sie doch
nachbacken ensuite family und das hier
ist ein bio zucker
den kann man doch wirklich über die
ganze weihnachts und adventszeit und
natürlich auch noch im nächsten jahr
benutzten zucker braucht man immer zum
beispiel zum wiener zucker aus
heimischen zucker bilden hat mich von
oetker
das finde ich cool cacau splitter mit
schoko tröpfchen und vollmilchschokolade
knusprig schokoladig
edgar roségold streu dekor und zwar ist
hier einmal sind die perlen drin
ok es jetzt echt ein schreiben wie man
es ausspricht ist es dann in französisch
streusel und konfetti markt fahren vom
land kennt alpakas wenn und zwar habe
ich jetzt hier in marzipan mit
orangengeschmack und dem acker mache das
echten richtig hochwertige smarts und
kann man zum backen benutzen kann man so
vermischen kann man also da kann man
echt ganz kreativ sein wirklich super
lecker habe ich auch schon sehr cool
name tube das ist eine marmelade aus der
tube die kenne ich tatsächlich nur weil
ich sie mal auf einer messe entdeckt
habe richtiges neues produkt als ich
habe jetzt hier update sind mit dabei
das heißt für euch kann jetzt auch eine
andere sorte mit dabei sein
kalifornische rosinen perfekt zum backen
und schnecken
kinder regel auch zu naschen kinder
schokolade mazzola keimöl müsste ein
maiskeimöl sein genau kenne ich von
meiner mama und die benutzt es auch
immer zum kauf von uns um banken meine
freunde aus wehen mama und hier haben
wir die orangen herzen was im herzen mit
feiner orange also meiner produkte liebe
ich alle aber die waffel herzen habe ich
auch eine flüssigkeit
wir haben hier kikkoman pon zu nehmen
eine sojasauce mit zitronen konzentrat
das sieht nach weihnachten aus
spekulatius gehört und lebkuchengewürz
von ostmann
das kann man immer gebrauchen
wird sagen das kommt jetzt als letztes
von stimmrechts kerrygold butter schmalz
also kerrygold butter kann nicht
kerrygold misch streichfett kenne ich
butterschmalz hatte ich jetzt noch nicht
sehr gut wird sagen das reicht jetzt
hier erst einmal hier sind die ganzen
lebensmittel die ganzen produkte und ich
überlege mir jetzt mal was ich darauf
machen werden aber ich glaube für ein
gerichts sind sie mir also zu schade das
heißt ich überlege jetzt einfach ob ich
zwei drei oder sogar vier kleine
weihnachtspräsente für euch kreiere und
probiere wirklich die zutaten und die
lebensmittel überall mit einzubeziehen
aber ihr seht schon mal ich habe ich
jetzt 20 türchen geöffnet und ich finde
jetzt weist jetzt kein lebensmittel
tritt dabei wo ich jetzt sagen würde
ohne ist nicht so mein fall
weil entweder kann man super zum backen
verwenden oder man kann es super sofort
schnecken oder man kann super zum kochen
offen also echt ok ich hier meine
gedanken und dann zeige ich euch jetzt
gleich weihnachtszeit vorschläge und
dann packen wir ich überlege mir jetzt
mal was sich aus den zutaten zubereiten
werde und überlege auch welche
geschmacksrichtungen ich kombiniere so
gefällt mir das ganz gut ich habe jetzt
hier vier gruppen gemacht und werde vier
backrezepte machen
zum einen habe ich mir jetzt überlegt zu
machen wir crêpes krebs war es was man
auf dem weihnachtsmarkt bekommt gehört
auf jeden fall zur weihnachtszeit dazu
den grip werde ich aus diesen zutaten
hier machen
dann habe ich mir gedacht machen wir ein
glas besser weil ein glas dass er auch
immer was ganz schnelles ist das heißt
wenn ihr spontan besuch bekommt könnt
ihr immer mal kurz im glas des zauber
wir werden cupcakes machen und dann habe
ich mir noch gedacht weil wir auch den
wolken im haus haben und zur besuch
gerade die vegane schokolade mache ich
noch was veganes also ein veganes
backhendl und ich starte jetzt erstmal
mit dem cap und dann kommt die nächsten
rezepte für den crap teig verwende ich
125 gramm hafermehl und 125 gramm
dinkelmehl zweier zwei teelöffel
sojasauce etwas spekulatius gewürzt und
500 gramm erbsen drink zum ausbacken
etwas butterschmalz und für die füllung
diese drei zutaten cortina nippon und
bananen
jetzt machen wir hier die crêpes ich
habe ich schon mal alle zutaten im
prinzip sind keine klassischen krebs
sondern eher pfannkuchen und dafür nehme
ich jetzt das hafermehl echt interessant
ist relativ neutral dinkelmehl die
zutaten kurz verrühren und durch das
hafermehl da sind wirklich ganz viele
ballaststoffe drin und durch das
dinkelmehl ist es ganz recht etwas
bekömmlicher jetzt kommen hier die eier
dazu
und statt der prise salz nehme ich jetzt
die sojasauce gericht wirklich extrem
lecker spekulatius gewürze spekulatius
gewürzt wirklich sehr wenig notieren ist
sehr aromatisch und dann noch den erbsen
drink das ruhig jetzt hier schon mal ein
und jetzt langsam den erbsen drink
dazugeben und dann kommt das mehl schön
von außen nach innen
[Musik]
doch gerade echt schön nach vanille man
hätte auch einfach über die pfannkuchen
machen können was man hier auch ganz gut
machen damit da ja der apps and drink
vegan ist könnt ihr auch die eier
weglassen und könnte pro 1 esslöffel
leinsamen nehmen schroten und dann
einfach mit wasser vermischen eine
viertelstunde stehen lassen und dann
habt ihr einen einsatz und könnte so
eben auch vegane pfannkuchen machen
ich hatte damals einen beitrag bei
galileo und da habe ich einfach
ersatzmittel also sozusagen benutzt und
hab das leinsamen benutzt und zwar recht
gut und da kann ich mir gut vorstellen
dass es hier bei den pfannkuchen auch
ganz gut klappt
den pfannkuchenteig jetzt einfach kurz
abdecken und eine halbe stunde ruhen
lassen und dann kann ich ihnen gleich
auspacken
was jetzt noch machen werden ist einmal
diese auszuprobieren
mal gespannt
vor allem wegen der zitrone oder
schmeckt echt gut also die könnte
bestimmt super auch in salatsaucen
benutzen
zum würzen mir schmeckt sie pur auch
sehr gut also schmeckt sie mir auch zu
sushi richtig gut und richtig schön 40
sehr gut die stecker ja das lasse ich
jetzt hier kurz ruhen und dann packen
wir die kann kochen auf und soll ein
problem noch den ärzten ring den ich
jetzt auch noch probleme
er riecht schon richtig lecker nach
vanille sauce
und schmeckt auch lecker da ist echt gut
und so leicht süßlich ist ob es passt
nicht gut mit den pfannkuchenteig ist
jetzt gequollen da ist jetzt etwas
dickflüssiger geworden das heißt ich
gebe es hier noch mal ein bisschen was
vom erbsen trinkt dazu jetzt nämlich
hier etwas butterschmalz geht's in meine
kräfte oder in eine anti haft
beschichtete pfanne und kann jetzt die
pfannkuchen heraus backen
der erste wird bei mir immer nicht so
schön ich glaube das bringt sowieso aber
der zweite wird dann umso schöner
schön auf mittel hoher hitze auspacken
und so eine eisenbahn ist da echt immer
ganz perfekt weil wirklich der krebs
schon auspackt und nicht an klebt das
heißt ich benutze jetzt beim ersten mal
bis in butterschmalz und dann brauche
ich fast gar nichts mehr
ich nehme aber nur für die nächsten ein
bisschen was dazu einfach auch wegen dem
schönen buttergeschmack
[Musik]
jetzt komme ich noch zu meiner
überraschung und zwar gibt ein tolles
gewinnspiel brennt news verlost nämlich
ab heute bis zum 30 november jeden tag
noch einen adventskalender
das heißt jeden tag die chance einen
adventskalender zu gewinnen
die infos findet ihr hier direkt bei
brandnooz auf der seite und die
verlosung findet auch dort statt
[Musik]
die crêpes packe ich jetzt hier noch aus
ich kann aber in der zwischenzeit schon
mal den rest vorbereiten
ich nehme jetzt sehen nippon schnitten
[Musik]
und schwere tier jetzt schmelzen über
dem wasserbad
das heißt hier habe ich einfach ein
bisschen wasser aufkochen lassen den
herd weder ausgestellt da gebe ich jetzt
oben rein
der kleine sind noch vorher ein bisschen
jetzt kann die schokolade hier auch
schön schmelzen
also ich hab mir gedacht ich nehme einen
pfannkuchen ein crêpe ich weiß nicht bei
uns daheim weil man ja mal hieß ist
einfach pfannkuchen und es war halt so
dünn wie crêpes habe ich das zugedreht
dann der schweizer schokolade den
aufstrich mit 45 prozent kakaoanteil
also schön schokolade und hier dachte
ich passen jetzt bananen wirklich gut
dazu
und dann auf rollen und für den kranz
obendrauf noch den schokoladen preis
daniele du darfst es probieren und sagt
das darf zuerst toll ich habe hier den
besten job nicht ausprobiert und bin
schon sehr gespannt hat es gibt eine
frische gab ja noch gedacht vielleicht
puderzucker oder von dem
spekulationsgewinn aber ich glaube dass
so aromatisch das reicht wirklich im
teig ich probiere das mal freunde hier
mal meine töchter empfand ich darf das
ständig mit den machen zusammen
das werde ich euch also was mir schon
aufgefallen ist beim ausparken hat man
einfach so einen richtig leckeren duft
durch den ersten drink und durch dieses
durch die spekulations gewürz super ja
richtig gut auf kurs bringen genau dass
die crunch schokoladig unternehmer nun
die banane dabei eine gute kombination
kriegt die meisten nicht so in also
meinen wir nicht so schön aus die
entsprechend aufgeräumt sieht man es
dann nicht mehr
ich bitte noch mal er hat mir gern
machen man kann es ja auch dann wirklich
schön aufschneiden und noch schön
anrichten hat man auch gleich ein
weihnachts des erst am ihre und ella die
fragen mich gefühlt jedes wochenende
ob der crêpes oder pfannkuchen und er
mache ich auch echt ganz gerne
tolle neue variante also klar so vielen
dank sehr schön ich mag dann darfst du
das essen ich bin halt noch die übrigen
zu und dann geht schon ans zweite rezept
da machen jetzt ein blitz rezept und ich
zeige euch mal die zutat
[Musik]
als nächstes gibt es jetzt ein veganes
rezept ein blitz rezept mit blätterteig
da kann man wirklich super schnell was
zaubern für das blitz rezept verwende
ich blätterteig den geht es im
tiefkühlfach oder im kühlfach etwas rum
oder apfelsaft die kalifornier rosinen
die weiße vegane schokolade und zum
dippen verwende ich dann noch dem mammut
you
zuerst werde ich jetzt mal den apfelsaft
mit den russinen vermischen
da wir das ganze jetzt packen sollen dem
backofen jetzt nicht verbrennen um so
gewinnen sie einfach zusätzlich nochmal
an aroma das können wir jetzt hier kurz
stehen lassen dann nehme ich jetzt in
blätterteig
den habe ich jetzt aus dem kühlfach und
blätterteig ist einfach schon von sich
aus wegen die schokolade gebrechlich
jetzt im kleines stückchen einfach hier
so ein bisschen und nehme jetzt
ausstecher normalerweise würde ich damit
kein teig außenrum verschwendet wird
jetzt eckige ausstecher nehmen aber weil
es weihnachtlich sein sondern nehme ich
jetzt hier diese ausstecher und dem
restlichen teig werde ich dann aber noch
mit backen gucke ich mal welche größe
ich nehme scheint hier die welt zwischen
größe okay ich hab es noch mal
unentschieden wir nehmen doch die runden
ausstattung
dann möchte ich überall gleichmäßig viel
füllung habe ja es ist perfekt und da
lege ich jetzt ein stück schokolade rein
und dann ein paar rosinen bestreicht den
rand hier so ein bisschen mit wasser
dadurch halten jetzt gleich beide
blätterteig klappen schön zusammen ich
kennzeichnet das ist einfach so ein
bisschen dann weiß ich nämlich wo die
füllung rein muss
jetzt die rosine noch drauf
jetzt lege ich hier die zweite platte
drauf ganz vorsichtig ihr könnt ihr
übrigens auch wenn ihr habt einen
ravioli maker benutzen und dann wirklich
ecken machen da habt ihr auch keinen
verschnitt dann habt ihr wirklich alles
schön verwendet aber ich mach das jetzt
für den ball kam und da freute sich
jetzt sehr schön die ecken
zusammendrücken die kanten
jetzt nehme ich dann ausstecher eine
schnelle celik gewählte seite steckt die
hier aus und legt sie dann auf ein
backblech
wichtig ist nur dass der rand schön zu
ist damit die schokolade nicht nach
außen läuft
wenn die rentner nicht ganz zu sind
können wir sie auch gerne mit einer
gabel noch zu drücken
dafür einfach aufs blech legen und dann
habt ihr auch gleichzeitig ein schönes
muster
ich habe jetzt noch die reste die kann
ich jetzt einfach weiter benutzen
ich nehme es eine pizza rad und schneide
kleine stückchen da ist echt egal wie
die kommen dann nämlich ganz wild hier
aufs backblech mit gebacken die großen
könnt ihr sogar noch zu wirbeln und
hiermit drauflegen wenn ihr sie vegan
halten wollt dann nehmt ihr jetzt am
besten etwas wasser und bestreicht sie
mit dem wasser und stellt dann noch
puderzucker drauf dann bekommen sie
nämlich im backofen auch einen glanz und
vor allem so eine leichte karamell koste
und wenn ihr sie jetzt nicht unbedingt
wegen haben wollt können da auch einfach
ein bisschen geld nehmen und trotzdem
gerne etwas puderzucker darauf streuen
und dann kommen sie schon in den
backofen und werden dann gemeinsam mit
der marmelade aus der tube serviert da
hole ich dann gleich den wolken zum
probieren und da bin ich mal gespannt
wie ihm dieses weihnachtsfest
[Musik]
stevic er nach dem backen noch etwas
puderzucker drauf und jetzt darf sarah
probieren denn der vulkan hat leider
kopfschmerzen daher keinerlei jetzt
nicht probieren da hat dein glück dein
auftritt wollte kam zum glück ist ein
glück was wir machen ist jetzt schneit
immer eins auf und dann es ist eine last
minute christmas idee mit blätterteig
liga
guckt mal weiße schokolade und rosinen
und als tipp dazu gibt es die marmelade
aus der tube und zwar ist es eine
apfelmarmelade
[Musik]
ich finde es vor allem fall cool ich
weiß nicht wie es bei euch daheim ist
aber gerade nicht
wir haben am frühstückstisch ein
streitthema und zwei systeme lade und
der marmeladen löffel denn ich lag da
immer so ein marmeladen löffelrein und
trotzdem das buttermesser und was
passiert nach drei tagen ist schüttelt
weil eben brotkrümel so viel moral
jakabfi schön dosieren direkt aufs brot
macht nichts hält zuschauer sie den
morath geworden und die füllung schmeckt
irgendwas schmeckst du raus heiße
schokolade schmeckt man es gut sie und
rosinen habe ich nicht viele aber schon
sowie ronny meyer genau beim noch eine
geschmeckt die marmelade private ich
muss auch probieren
ich bin dafür dass müssen gefährlich mit
der l mit der tube weil die ella gemacht
die wir dann direkt gegen und hier ist
das auch noch ok und was ich jetzt
gerade ist die praktische beschützt
ihren fruchtaufstrich nachhaltig vor
sonnenlicht hält ihn länger frisch und
ist zu 100 prozent recycelbar
also hab auch noch den vorteil dass es
eben nicht geschützt ist echt gut und
würde gerne einmal auf jeden fall sehr
gut auf jeden fall
dann gebe ich dir diesen teller ihr
dürft gerne die fotos machen und sg war
ich mache weiter mit rock nummer drei
[Musik]
das dritte rezept werden jetzt cupcakes
und hier habe ich jetzt auch einige zu
haben die ich dafür wirklich supergut
benutzen kann
ich werde es nämlich cupcakes machen mit
einer kinder schokoladencreme da kommt
einen kern aus marzipan dann nehme ich
das orangen marzipan und ja noch die
ganzen anderen tollen zutaten für den
teig nämlich 150 gramm zucker eine prise
salz 200 gramm mehl einen viertel
teelöffel natron und einen halben
teelöffel backpulver 250 gramm
maiskeimöl 150 gramm butter milch 50
gramm von der backmischung und 200 gramm
marzipan
hier habe ich noch die zutaten für die
creme und dafür verwende ich 100 gramm
sahne kinderriegel 300 gramm frischkäse
300 gramm sahne und sträucher in
roségold ich nehme hier zuerst die
trockenen zutaten also zucker und salz
dann noch mehl backpulver und natron
kurz verrühren
wenn wir jetzt komme ich hier die
flüssigen zutaten rein also dass
maiskeimöl passt hier natürlich auch
hervorragend weil es wirklich
geschmacksneutral ist und man das eben
auch zum backen benutzen kann
buttermilch so könnten auch den erbsen
trinkt benutzen aber der selbst schon
leer denn ich habe fast komplett alles
für die crêpes aufgebraucht und den rest
getrunken
kurz berühren
und dann kommen jetzt hier nur noch die
trockenen zutaten mit rein werden
eingerührt und da kommen jetzt noch die
back mischok drops rein und da habt ihr
wirklich jetzt auch diese cacau naps mit
dabei ich suche dir mal raus hier
richtig schön scharf eingebrochen hat er
es wir sind im prinzip nicht süß sondern
da hat man einfach die pure schokolade
also die kakaobohne und dann kommt dazu
eben noch in kombination die vollmilch
schokolade und die show getrotzt und die
sind backfest echt gut und vor allem hat
man auch nach dem backen und schönen
crash der teig ist fertig das ging recht
fix
deswegen mag ich cupcakes auch so gerne
jetzt fühle ich die förmchen mit einem
eis portionierer dann nehme ich dann
immer den großen
und ich hatte jetzt zuerst überlegt das
waren einfach zu zerkleinern und mit in
den teig zu geben
dann habe ich mir aber gedacht nehmen
wir machen wie so eine art
marzipankartoffeln also einfach ein
kleines stück nehmen in der hand formen
und dann nehme ich jetzt auch das orange
marzipan und das drücke ich jetzt hier
rein als marzipan kern im muffin
[Musik]
normalerweise klettert der teig jetzt
noch über den muffin aber es kann auch
sein dass er teilweise offen bleibt
ihr könnt ihn gerne noch abdecken muss
aber nicht wenn es rauskommt ist auch
okay
das kleine stückchen das ist jetzt halt
noch für mich schön mit orange jetzt
können die cupcakes schon gebacken
werden
zwischenzeitig creme vorbereiten mit
vollem mund spricht man nicht
[Musik]
die creme stelle ich jetzt heraus sahne
und kinder riegel
das heißt ich nehme jetzt erstmal eine
kleine menge sahne das heißt 100 gramm
die erwärmung jetzt also lasst sie kurz
aufkochen
ich habe dann gleich die kinder
schokolade dazu geben also eine garage
nach dem aufkochen dann einfach in die
saane eindruck dass sie den herd jetzt
ausstellen
[Musik]
perfekt sitze aus und die fülle ich
jetzt umstellen sie in den kühlschrank
lacht die muffins hier hinter mir fertig
backen und sobald alles abgekühlt und
durch gekühlt ist geht es weiter mit dem
kampik
[Musik]
die cupcakes dann abgekühlt die kinder
schokoladencreme ist auch kalt
die gebe ich jetzt schon mal direkt in
eine große rührschüssel ich sehe auch
die ist schön dickflüssig und die könnte
die jetzt im prinzip einfach so
aufschlagen und habe dann der kinder
schokoladen sahne
aber ich werde jetzt noch verfeinern
frischkäse passt nämlich ganz gut
also hier jetzt die hälfte des
frischkäse dazugeben und den rest in
eine andere schüssel und jetzt früher
ist die hier schon mal
[Musik]
hier wird die hälfte oder sahne dazu
und kann die creme dann mit etwas salat
schlagen und den restlichen frischkäse
die restliche sahne und das sommerbad
schlag ich jetzt auch noch steigt und
dann habe ich einfach zwei verschiedene
cremes eine china schokoladencreme und
eine helle kriegen
wisst ihr nicht machen aber könnt ihr
hier können doch eine gesamt klären
[Musik]
jetzt habt ihr hier eine helle und eine
dunkle creme und einen spritzbeutel mit
nach stern töne vorne und ich schicke
dir ne zum klicken hier rein und stets
versuchen die eine hälfte des
spritzbeutel mit der hellen creme zu
führen und die andere dann mit der
dunklen
[Musik]
und wenn es jetzt klappt beim ersten
wird vielleicht nicht funktionieren
aber dann kommt dieser strang doppel
farbe kraus und ich habe einen
zweifarbigen cupcake
[Musik]
und um die cupcakes jetzt auch fertig zu
dickeren nämlich noch den streik in
roségold streut doch drüber und fertig
sind die weihnachts cupcakes
ihr zweites probieren sanierer und
daniela ich würde sagen weil wir jetzt
schon ein paar rezepte probiert haben
halt jeden fall den oder nicht gut aber
andere aussehen tut schon mal was ist
das denn
das ist ein cupcake mit einer marzipan
füllung eine marching band den schauen
wir uns jetzt gleich genauer an und
einer kinder schokoladencreme
[Musik]
guckt euch diesen kern an diesen park
erstes orangen marzipan ja genau
jetzt meldet sich ja sehen dass
schokolade kinder schokolade macht ihr
nicht und dann habe ich da einen teig
noch diese bank festen schoko drops mit
kakao nidderaus das ist später
nachmittag
es ist aber nicht so süß dass ich nicht
gut man kann den geschmack natürlich
verstecken wenn man merkte nimmt aber
ich habe jetzt zwei übrig gelassen
zuzulassen
ich finde der geschmacklich definitiv
aus
[Musik]
ich finde den maßnahmen vor allem mit
der orange echt schön und bei geknackt
sind es die russen und befindest du gut
geld dass am code schokoladen und ich
finde man schmeckt auch das maßband gar
nicht so aus es gibt ja auch menschen
die möglichkeit marzipan
aber da finde ich überwiegt so der
orangengeschmack bildung muss man auf
jeden fall wirklich mal ausprobieren der
frank schüttelt den kopf er mag nämlich
kein marzipan
aber ich glaube das schmeckt dir echt
wort musst du mal ausprobieren
das rezept nummer drei und jetzt kommt
noch ein viertes rezept und da hab ich
mir jetzt gedacht machen wir ein schönes
glasschicht dass er so aus dem glas weil
ich finde zur capex in hübsch aus alles
andere hat jetzt auch bis sehr gut
gefallen aber ein glas des
weihnachtszaubers schön ist und vor
allem kann man schön vor portionieren
und im kühlschrank stellen und hat es
schon schön bereit
jeder kann sich seine lieblings schicht
füllen
also jetzt ist es her
[Musik]
hier bin ich jetzt mal gespannt denn ich
mache hier verschiedene schichten im
glas des er zuerst wollte ich eigentlich
was ganz einfach machen was man wirklich
schnell und last minute auch machen kann
jetzt ist ein bisschen aufwendiger also
ein schönes weihnachtliches dass er
vielleicht auch für heiligabend für das
glas bisher nämlich heidel werden aus
dem gefrierfach orangensaft etwas gaga
zum binden
für die creme brauche ich sahne quark
die bio orangenschale und den mieter
egger trüffel und zum schichten verwende
ich noch die waffel herzen und die
gebrannten mandeln
ich nehme jetzt zuerst den orangensaft
stecker und jeden topf und darf dann
gemeinsam mit dem akg aufkochen
insgesamt zwei minuten lang gaga ist
übrigens ein pflanzliches geliermittel
also eine tolle alternative zur gelatine
das will ich jetzt kurzum einfach nur
damit ich es besser eingießen kann
denn mit dem topf werde ich bestimmt
lecker jetzt mache ich so ich nehme
jetzt die gefrorenen himbeeren
heidelbeeren und lass dir jetzt auch
gefroren dadurch kühlt nämlich die der
orangensaft einfach auch schnell ab geht
es hier jetzt noch leser
da gehe ich jetzt den orangensaft drauf
und wie hat dann leicht rührt kommt
wirklich die tolle farbe der blaubär
raus und durch die kälte stellt auch
wirklich total schnell das stelle ich
jetzt ganz kurz in den kühlschrank
jetzt geht es schon direkt weiter mit
der creme ich nehme es die hälfte der
saane die klassik kurz aufkochen dem
topf habe ich mittlerweile ausgewaschen
also da ist es kein orangensaft mehr
drin und kann jetzt hier die trüffel
auspacken und da habe ich jetzt von
niederegger die blue berry cheesecake
trüffel genommen mit der füllung guck
mal als praktisch die cheesecake füllung
mit drin und außen drum die schokolade
die werde ich dann gleich schmelzen mit
der sahne könnt ihr auch gerne so ein
bisschen zerkleinern
und sobald die sahne kocht wird sie
direkt über die trüffel gegossen
jetzt noch schön rühren und schmerzen
findet man riecht jetzt hier auch schon
richtig die blaubeeren raus deswegen
habe ich als erste schicht auf blauen
und orangen genommen das kompliziert zur
seite darf abkühlen und muss wirklich
wieder auf kühlschranktemperatur kommen
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich hier
die orangen creme machen dafür nehme ich
die sahne die hälfte des quax und die
orangenschale das weiß ich denn jetzt
einfach hier einmal sahne die hälfte des
quark den übrigen quark nehme ich nehme
ich dann die trüffel masse und die
orangenschale dann nehme ich jetzt gar
nicht alles denn in der packung war ich
ganz viel drin also wirklich der abrieb
von einer ganzen branche so viel brauche
ich gar nicht ich nehme jetzt nur ein
bisschen was und kann jetzt die zutaten
verrühren und steif schlagen
[Musik]
die stelle ich jetzt auch kurz kühl und
dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder wenn
beide massen kalt sind
jetzt ist die creme schön kalt und ich
kann jetzt auch hier den quark dazugeben
und dann die creme steif schlagen
[Musik]
und dann könnt ihr die creme in einen
spritzbeutel füllen mit großer
machtfülle so mache ich das jetzt weil
ich dann die krähen besser einfühlen
kann
und dann direkt in die gläser füllen
[Musik]
das gefällt mir so schon mal richtig gut
jetzt kommen die herzlichen zum einsatz
die waffel herzen
die werde ich jetzt einfach in würfel
schneiden eigentlich ganz schade denn
diese sind echt schön
ich würde gern lieber als deko benutzen
aber vielleicht setzt sich ja noch eins
oben drauf
[Musik]
das riecht schon richtig weihnachtlich
da riecht man wirklich die orange ganz
gut raus jetzt fühle ich noch die
orangen creme ein
gebt ihr noch obendrauf wobei ich finde
es zwar so schon richtig perfekt aber
die orangen können ich glaube die macht
dann auch noch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und hier kommen jetzt noch die
gebrannten mandeln braucht die hab ich
jetzt noch ein bisschen
[Musik]
ich würde sagen das darf jetzt das thema
probieren
de facto darfst probier ich habe noch
besser schmeckt wenn es ein bisschen
durchzieht aber ich glaube so ist schon
gut aber ich habe meine vier vorbereitet
also ist sie auf jeden fall schonmal
wandeln ja okay ich kann es dir
vielleicht sagen und dann habe ich halt
bären mit orangen dann die erste creme
ist 100 raffl creme internet auch mit
blaubeeren der blogger cheesecake und
damit ist in waffeln mit orangen und
oben ist noch mal eine helle creme mit
orange und dann als topping die
gebrannten mandeln
also ich habe jetzt mal oben ist wie so
ein naturjoghurt kümmern seien zwar
nicht so süß weil unten es halt alles
ungesetzliche echt lecker vor allem das
wird von unten immer milder also unten
ist ganz süß und dann morgen herr müller
genau das gefällt mir costa rica
unterhalt zu verschiedenen konsistenzen
das war diese frucht masse aber bis zum
schluss projektor einfach jemanden hart
daran wieder von fruchtig creme zudem
mitgenommen wird dir das als weihnachts
der sehr gefallen ich würde sagen passt
zu weihnachten dann hoffe ich dass du
den adventskalender ist dann kann es
ausprobieren und ich kann sagen wir uns
der markt schmeckt schmeckt uns allen
was schon sein geschmack der für den
viele haben ja weil immer wenn es
schmeckt dann schmeckt auch den meisten
anderen
das haben unsere nie gesagt sogar ja
aber nicht so süß oder gar nicht okay
ich habe oben extra keinen zucker dran
weil unten so ein bisschen dunkel aber
auch nicht zu sauer weil oft die börsen
die zusage aber hier ist das gerät nicht
perfekt dann haben wir hier unser
viertes rezept und irgendwann verkoster
sie aber ich danke auch
[Musik]
ja das war es jetzt im prinzip schon ich
habe aus den lebensmitteln des
adventskalenders vier gerichte gezaubert
ich hoffe euch haben die rezepte
gefallen und vor allem hoffe ich dass
euch die produkte und die lebensmittel
gefallen haben ich muss echt sagen dass
wirklich gar kein produkt dabei war kein
lebensmittel was mir nicht gefallen hat
und alle eignen sich hervorragend zum
backen oder auch zum gleich vernaschen
oder zum gleich trinken und schreibt mir
gerne eure kommentare unten rein und wie
gesagt gibt es auch das gewinnspiel das
heißt wenn ihr jeden tag einen
adventskalender gewinnen wollt habt ihr
die chance dazu schaut einfach nochmal
bei bremste er vorbei ich bedanke mich
bei euch allen für einschalten die
rezepte gibt es natürlich in meiner
kostenlosen app oder auf dem blog wie
immer auch sallys - blog.de also viel
spaß mit dem adventskalender und wir
sehen uns wieder beim nächsten mal